ron thank you very much it is 6 15 here
on a friday morning hey you know we talk
about the golden knights all the time
but we can't forget about
the new hockey team in town of course
the henderson silver knights because
they are off to a rocket start this year
and we're joined this morning live by
the team's head coach manny veveros
joining us to talk about how things are
going
in year one here in the valley coach
vivevos thanks for joining us this
morning how you doing
i'm good thanks thanks for having me on
appreciate you joining us
uh well let's let's quickly talk about
where things stand right now you guys
are off to a flying start
in your first season playing in the
american hockey league we know the
challenges of the nhl what's it been
like playing
at the at the ahl level you know very
similar
uh you know our protocols uh just like
the nhl are very uh very similar
you know our players got us commend our
players and our staff
they've done a wonderful job so far uh
we've had not one single
positive test and
our players are basically they're going
to the rank and going home and
you know we know how fortunate we are
right now to be able to work in these
type of
times right now so but a great great job
of our players and our style
i actually had the chance to play myself
over at lifeguard arena down in downtown
henderson this week it's a beautiful
facility very similar to city national
out in summerlin so you guys have a
top-notch facility
and it's certainly proving it's worth
you guys are 11 and two to start the
season
helped a lot by goalie oscar dance he's
played with the golden knights as well
48 saves in his last game talk about his
play
no oscar who has been outstanding uh for
all our goaltending uh this year and
henderson have been outstanding here
um you certainly don't want your
goaltender to be your best uh player
ever sing in late especially giving up
that many shots on that but
we certainly got him back into form real
quick um
so hopefully this weekend we won't give
him as much work and still have the same
success
you're saying you don't want to have him
have to make 48 saves every night that's
not normal come on now
he can do it right no he's certainly
he's certainly earned his paycheck that
night here but that's you know again
it's a team sport and you certainly need
a guy stepping up
he certainly stole one for us that night
for sure so another reason to talk about
the
the henderson silver knights you guys
are playing at the orleans arena right
now where your while your new arena is
being built down
near green valley ranch and for the
first time you're going to have fans at
the games this weekend you guys must be
looking forward to that
absolutely our players have been talking
about it all week long
you know at the end of the day our
players are you know they're
entertainers and they love to play in
front of fans and
and friends and family and uh so it's an
opportunity that even though it's
limited uh just to have that live
interaction
and hear that live noise from cheering
from our own fans
for the first time in history of the
organization it's going to be really
real special so again fans will be
allowed in for the first time tomorrow
in the game
against the san jose barracuda and for
folks who haven't maybe been following
the nights
uh the silver knights as closely as
maybe they follow the golden knights
what kind of a team have you put
together how would you describe the guys
how would you describe the
the way they uh they take on their
opponents what would they see when they
see them take the ice well the
organization uh keller mckerman and
george mcphee and his
uh uh scouting staff have put a an
excellent team together
uh you know they build an organization
on speed and skill
uh very similar uh to how cool the
knights are built and
that's the type of play that we want to
emulate when we're on the ice as much as
possible and so far we've got a really
good job of that but
you're going to see a lot of
similarities
well coach v rose thanks for joining us
talking about the henderson silver
knights a lot of those guys might
hopefully end up on the golden knights
at some point in the future we look
forward to seeing them on the ice
this weekend again san jose good luck to
you the rest of the season appreciate it